mark joining us mark was at the Patriots
game last night you stayed for the whole
game I did I feel grain drink but you
know what it's you know we lost two
games I mean we just went out I mean
there's one game to win and that's the
Super Ball
so the regular-season game was a tough
loss especially I was there with my son
when we were there for a Sunday night
game was a couple years ago against
attack season
my son used to seeing them win so he was
bummed out but you know what are you
gonna do what about pass interference on
the last play
did you have a problem with the no call
on Gronk Oh certainly hoping for a flag
but you know I mean the last position
came away with a field goal I mean he
kind of jo-jo but the classic thing
we're all kind of giggling about after
he Carroll going for two even though if
they kicked her point of that an eight
point lead
yeah was strange strategy there if you
do the math because but I thought what
he was saying is I don't know if we can
hold off the Patriots with just you know
one time when I'm gonna force them to
get to scores instead of one but it was
interesting about a cheating here by
Pete Carroll yeah but you know look I
mean really lucky to hold him the field
goal those first three possessions
anyway and it was like you know it was
uh it was just a tough game but it
happened okay what happens when you're
in a suite and you know somebody who's
there probably wants to talk movies more
than they do sports but you'd rather
talk sports than movies so or watch the
game so how's that work where you be and
Mark Wahlberg are polite in a way to get
your message across that you just like
to watch the game well actually how do
you know what I was good because I was
surrounded by people that really just
wanted to talk about the game or I was
also sitting with Boston Police
Commissioner Bill Evans who instrumental
in the movie Patriots Day as well as a
body burner and so they were right there
with me who is kind of part of the
character that
play movie Philip Eric the character of
a couple of different cops and so
getting to talk to them meeting their
kids and being in my son's we were we
were what if you know it that has happen
if you do get a movie question and I
didn't know if you would last night
about somebody asking about shooting Ted
to where you know Brady's in the movie
did that question come out did that come
up last night it didn't come up last
night does come up in many many times I
just watch the scene again and you know
Brady seemed it so how does that work
when you say to Brady
hey here's the deal this is what we need
we need you know we need you to give
some assistance to Ted so we can have a
baby since Ted's a teddy bear and you
can't have a baby and we need some
contributions from you Tom we told them
we said look if there was like the
perfect person to be a donor who would
be right of course everybody you know in
this world would think Tom Brady make a
super baby and he just thought it was
funny you know he just got I just kind
of pitched him thankfully you know the
first movie already come out with a huge
success when people kind of got the joke
but he was completely game but do you
place the call to Tom or does the script
go to him and then you follow uh no I
reached out to him and asked them I told
what it was then we had a send it to him
he's Mark Wahlberg patriot state comes
out December 21st but you have this show
shooter with Ryan Philippi and that's
tomorrow night at 10:00 Eastern what
what did you love so much about this
that you stayed involved with this you
know we actually we shot the movie in
the oh seven you know we we loved it
there's so much more stuff in the source
material you know we always felt like
you know there could be a number of
movies but because there's so many books
we figured um following Bob Lee swagger
we said it we could easily it would
definitely play better at the TV show
hmm and then so when we talked to
Paramount partnering up with the USA and
we just thought you know there's a much
better way to continue the story so it's
the journey of Bob Lee swagger decorated
veteran and
back into action to prevent a plot to
kill the president so Ryan Philip II is
that where it picks up when yeah okay
uh-huh
kind of picks up where the movie was and
then from there so that over the next
ten episodes is on hold this journey do
you have a cameo ah they didn't offer me
one yet but I'm waiting patiently Wow
I thought you know it would be cool for
me and him to just kind of meet um
somewhere along the lines but maybe at
some point a rim ride an incredible job
on the show you know we uh you know
neither the guy really be believable and
somebody that yo guys girls age I do uh
how many times you played a ball why we
want to have a hit maybe how many times
you played a bad guy um I played a
really bad bad guy just Basketball
Diaries fear hmm but I played some
questionable characters basketball
Lori's likes it been a long long time
ago did DiCaprio could he play bass
tomorrow oh look at you lying how's your
daughter doing since you know she she
got really famous there on the show last
time you were on oh man I'm not even I'm
supposed to be allowed to be on the show
now without her after a little bit yeah
I know you know my wife said wait did
you ask mark if he could have his
daughter on I said I don't think his
daughter was in the mood to wait for
mark to say was it was it okay for her
to come on the show she was in charge of
it it was one of the I never had more
fun well hey good to talk to you safe
travels are you planning your schedule
around this
Super Bowl in case the Patriots or when
the Patriots are in I am and I promise
now because I just took my juice on
glass night so my wife was mad my two
girls were upset that they know I do
stuff with the boys
so everybody is playing I'm going to the
Super Bowl well good luck we see
unfortunately we're only going with the
pastor there so all right well good luck
with that but more importantly with with
the show and always good to talk to you
thanks mark thanks buddy
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience